et pour en parler on retrouve stéphane
rozès politologue et enseignant à hec
sciences-po aussi rené chiche professeur
de philosophie les vice-présidents
action et démocratie cfe cgc
bonsoir messieurs merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur arte france alors on l'a
vu après cette journée d'hommage hier
qui se poursuit donc que ce samedi
encore un an après le casse hasina de
samuel pas de fille on a aussi vu jean
michel blanquer le maire de
conflans-sainte-honorine inauguré un
livre ouvert en hommage dont l
enseignant et pour rappeler aussi
l'importance de la liberté d'expression
selon vous stéphane rozès ce genre de
symbole de rappel est indispensable
c'est indispensable est en tout cas la
mesure de la révélation pour l'opinion
publique et sans doute une partie des
guérites chaud sur ce qui se passait
dans l'éducation nationale à depok
80% des français
estimaient au vu du déroulement des
fêtes que la laïcité était en danger et
80 % des français la même proportion
estimé que l'essence et une on avait
tout à fait le droit eux dans le cadre
de l'école de faire circuler des
caricatures de religion dans le cadre de
leur enseignement
l'enchaînement au fond de cette affaire
a montré que le crime aurait pu être
évité de la part de ce terroriste si une
chaîne de responsabilités de laïcité au
tour de samuel pâtit sorte de cordon
immédiat sanitaire de protection de
samuel pâtir cet effet ça ne s'est pas
fait parce que des logiques de
l'éducation nationale autour de pâtes
bague il faut pas se montrer se
stigmatisent et plus au fond une
rencontre au fil des années au train
forme de gauchisme culturel
devenu d'ailleurs intersectionnelle pour
certains plus ni conception néolibérale
de l'école selon laquelle au fond le
relativisme
les élèves doit être mise au sens tout
ça c'est que rue à comprendre pour les
français y dit que ça me baby était seul
qui devait se cacher que les référents
et responsable laïcité sa hiérarchie
directe ne le protégeait pas et donc
lutter seul face à un engrenage d'une
manipulation dont les réflexes premier
six habitées républicain hilali aurait
pu éviter cet engrenage
au départ il ya mensonge
les actions d'un fichier s il ya les
réseaux sociaux il ya l'arrivée du
meurtrier il ya bref tout un
environnement qui rend le meurtre de
samuel pâtit possible et là l'opinion a
commencé à comprendre la gravité au fond
d'une école peu à peu laissée à elle
même des enseignants devant faire face
en première ligne est une idéologie
mêlant new libéralisme gauchisme
intersectionnelle qui commence à avoir
des effets on le voit dans les ultimes
auprès des jeunes enseignants
il semble moins convaincus que la nation
de l'importante de la laïcité de la
défense des fondamentaux de la
république dans lesquelles les
différentes religions ne peuvent mener
si c'est ce que vous vous estimez vous
aussi que samuel pâtir s'est retrouvé
seul face à une tragédie qui aurait pu
être évitée
merci votre bon interlocuteur notre
invité
dix ans de choses beaucoup trop beaucoup
trop et en mettant à peu près tout sur
le même plan dont je voudrais quand même
profiter de l'occasion qui m'est donnée
pour
rappeler
la réalité parce que samuel bâti n'est
pas mort pour les valeurs de la
république il n'est pas mort pour la
liberté d'expression il n'est pas mort
pour la laïcité
pourquoi est il mort il est mort parce
que une mère d'élève le 6 octobre 2020
dix jours avant cette décapitation
a téléphoné à la principale de son
collège pour
l'accuser d'avoir stigmatisé
des élèves de confession musulmane de
les avoir fait quitter la salle et il
s'est avéré
que sept accusations étaient fausses
qu'elles avaient été
formulées par une élève qui n'était même
pas présente alors il faut que vos
auditeurs comprennent bien ceux ci la
première chose qu'il fallait faire
c'était de vérifier cette accusation est
d'étouffer dans l'oeuf cette rumeur
avant qu'elle ne désigne samuel patty a
d'autres qui se sont emparés de cette
histoire pour d'autres logiques il y a
dans cette affaire en réalité deux
choses qu'il faut absolument distinguer
et ne surtout pas confondre en me
faisant surtout pas d' amalgame il y a
d'un côté
un problème avec l'islamisme le
séparatisme islamique qui s'est emparée
de cette affaire et qui aboutit à
l'exécution absolument abominable atroce
de samuel bâti il yad'un côté d'un autre
côté le fonctionnement ordinaire
quotidien de l'éducation nationale et à
ce sujet je voudrais commencer par dire
une chose quand je vois les images des
ministres de l'éducation nationale
je suis
vraiment en colère j'éprouve un profond
dégoût quand je vois les hommages qui
sont rendus par des autorités qui n'ont
pas été là qui refusent même de voir la
réalité en face et qui ont couvert
des rapports mensongers établi par
l'inspection générale de l'éducation
nationale sur ce qui s'est réellement
passé où on ose ou non aux reprocher à
ce professeur de ne pas avoir
correctement maîtrisé la laïcité voilà à
quel point mon vendée où madame pécresse
qui défilent aujourd'hui à côté du
ministre de l'éducation nationale ose
écrire sur twitter aujourd'hui même que
les professeurs ont besoin d'une
formation à la licité mennucci
même rené fiche que vous rejoignez
séphane rozès sur le fait que samuel
pâti à s'est retrouvé un petit peu seul
dans sa situation qu'est ce qui aurait
dû être fait selon vous fait donc je
veux donner la parole tout d'abord à ses
fans rozès
je suis en radical d accord avec ce que
je viens d'entendre
je ne comprends pas cette difficulté à
reconnaître qu'il ya une offensive des
islamistes
une offensive
théologico politique de nature bien
concrète je ne comprends pas c'est dit
cette façon de mettre sur le même pied
d'égalité
ceux qui n'ont pas eu les bons réflexes
pour des raisons idéologiques
culturelles
et ceux qui étaient dans le padd vague
et ceux qui ont pas pris la mesure du
danger moi je mets pas du tout sur le
même au même niveau les idiots utiles
les compagnons de route des alliés
objectifs des islamistes à l'intérieur
de l'école et dans une certaine moche et
d'autre part ni chaîne une très
certainement de l'institution par
rapport à ce que cette affaire arrive et
donc effectivement il faut reprendre
absolument
on ment au fond il ya une grande culture
les gens ne j'entendais un représentant
france info vous remettre en cause des
choix
pédagogiques de sa nouvelle patrie en
l'occurrence à lieutenant de mélenchon
corbières en faisant la grave erreur de
considérer que la laïcité
c'était la critique des religions et la
laïcité c'est pas du tout la critique
des religions dont siam culture
globale
du fait que les gens connaissent pas
l'histoire de france ils savent pas ce
qu'est rabelais savent pas les raisons
très ancienne et très profond qui fait
qu'on s'assemblent en des naturalisant
nos origines part des discounts des
blagues des caricatures bref il ya une
inculture totale parce que pendant des
années la formation des maîtres sur
toutes ces questions a été laissée en
jachère pour les raisons diverses et de
nature un peu de l'hiver ce que j'ai
entendu donc effectivement il faut
reprendre la formation des enseignants
j'entends beaucoup de la part y compris
d'enseignants qui ne pas savoir un peu
de quoi il parle beaucoup
d'inexactitudes
de mai situations de l'importance dans
ce qui tient ensemble de construire un
avenir commun nous enfoncent la
république la laïcité dans la république
et la laïcité
rené fils excusez moi c'est valrose
elles sont on va on va manquer on va
manquer de temps malheureusement est ce
que rené chiche vous estimez qu'il ya en
mai comprend une incompréhension sur la
laïcité ou dites moi ce que vous voulez
les plombs oui tout ce que voulait
répondre à ses fans je vous en prie ben
oui je suis obligé de réagir parce que
monsieur rozès ne se rend pas compte il
est en train de doucement de donner un
nouveau coup de poignard dans le corps
de samuel pâtit parsemé disque libre il
est en train de mettre caen qu'il est en
train de mettre en cause la formation il
est en train de faire de mettre en cause
la formation et la capacité des
professeurs à faire leur métier or c'est
de se que samuel patinoire il faut à un
moment donné être honnête moi je mets je
lis je sais pas je sais pas
monsieur rosas laissez moi parler je
vous ai laissé parler laissez moi parler
jusqu'au bout je sais par vous m'accuser
de minorer le l'acte islamique je ne le
mineur pas du tout simplement
j'insiste sur ce qui est occultée parce
que ce qui est occulté dérange parce que
ce qui occulte et renvoie la société à
son apport à l'école et à l'autorité et
au savoir en réalité ce qui a été à
l'origine de cette affaire c'est que
n'importe qui aujourd'hui se croit
permis de contester l'enseignement d'un
d'un professeur un professeur qui est
recrutée par concours un professeur dont
la compétence doit être respectée je
vous savez que dans le droit français il
ya la présomption d'innocence dans
l'éducation nationale non seulement dit
qu'un professeur fait l'objet d'une
plainte il est présumé coupable mais en
plus il est présumé incompétent et je ne
supporte pas qu'on présente cette
affaire en disant qu'il faut que les
professeurs et une formation
supplémentaire à la laïcité car c'est
exactement aller dans le sens de ce qui
lui a été reprochée y compris par
l'inspection générale qui a considéré
que ce collègue ne maîtrisez pas
suffisamment la laïcité je ne supporte
plus ce genre de discours parce que
encore une fois ils ont comme
conséquence ce qui s'est passé alors si
on n'est pas capable de voir ce qui
s'est passé et là effectivement tous les
hommages qui sont rendus sont hypocrites
ce sont les hommage du vice à la vertu
si vous voulez maintenant que je dise ce
qu'il faut faire ce qu'il faut faire
pour être digne de la mémoire de samuel
bâti et bien mon propre syndicat l'a
proposée sous la forme de l'amendement
sable elle pâtit il faut que vos et 10h
aussi sache que monsieur le ministre
blanc caire
tellement
désireux de donner à une loi le slogan
qui l'a choisie pour incarner son action
c'est à dire les codes de la confiance a
inscrit dans le code de l'éducation
un article qui détruit l'autorité
professoral en la soumettant à
l'engagement et l'exemplarité de l'agent
et gd la mort de samuel pâtit proposé
que vont réécrit cette fois parce que le
respect de l'autorité de l'enseignant
dépend de la fonction et non pas de la
manière de servir donc ce respect doit
être exigé par la loi et bien tout a été
fait pour que cet amendement ne soient
pas acceptés y compris av mes propres
collègues représentants de différents
syndicats au sein du conseil supérieur
de l'éducation qui ont refusé de prendre
part au vote parce qu'il était gêné
parce qu'on lance c'est dans cet
amendement est temps que la société ne
verra pas en face le problème de l'école
qui est celui de l'autorité et qui est
la cause véritable de tous les maux
quand on se plaint ensuite eh bien on
n'en sortira pas et on n'aura hélas et
moi on est en tant que syndicaliste
d'autres salles de la parole une
dernière fois ses fans rozès
vous attend stéphane rozès sur le
territoire manqua à l'école également
selon vous ce que je viens d'entendre ya
effectivement une conception qui est
devenu marchande de l'éducation
nationale comme une sorte de supermarché
autour de l'idée que la société
arriverait avec ce qu'elle est et chacun
trois lieux où elle apparaît donc je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce que je
viens d'entendre néanmoins il ne faut
pas à relativiser comme ça été fait
jusqu'à maintenant de façon générale la
portée le propos
l'intelligence et du propos
islamistes et sa singularité dans
l'éducation nationale cissé n'était que
ça se serait pas si grave mais serbie a
rencontré une crise de la république qui
n'arrivent plus à donner
en tout ces enfants et puis sa rencontre
idéologiquement au fond des idéologies
parallèle même s'ils savent n'apparaît
pas la fois effectivement des idéologies
néolibérale
universaliste et puis des idéologies au
fond intersectionnelle ou pourquoi on
ennuierait au fond les croyances
religieuses
donc il ya beaucoup de points sur
lesquels nous sommes d'accord ensemble
mais je ne relativise pas du tout le
danger islamiste et ses relais chez
voilà merci vous avez donc le quelques
points d'accord tout de même tous les
deux malheureusement nous arrivons à la
fin de ce débat je vous remercie
stéphane rozès je rappelle que vous êtes
politologue et président de la cenap et
enseignant à hec et sciences-po et merci
à vous également rené chiche
vice-président action et démocratie cfe
cgc